welcome to the Monster Hunter world
technical Weapon series switchbacks the
adaptable switch axe can transform
between a long reaching axe and a swift
sort wreak havoc in axe mode and then
unleash the swords element discharged
for a devastating blow to your target
charge played incredibly versatile the
charge blade can morph from a sword and
shield combo into a high-powered axe is
to use the sword and shield combo to
store energy and releases destructive
force in acts mode
insect glaive insect glaive is a weapon
for those who like to take their fight
to the skies boasting incredible
mobility the insect glaive enables
aerial assaults from all angles combined
with the use of kin sex to receive
boosts the Gladers are formidable choice
of weaponry
[Music]
[Music]
hunting-horn
the heroic hunting-horn allows you to
perform stat boosting melodies for you
and your fellow hunters but don't take
the support weapon for granted it still
packs a mighty punch
[Music]
whoa
the bow is an elegant agile weapon
allows you to rain down an array of
arrows upon your prey
applying coatings to your arrows will
allow you to inflict various status
ailments to your wings tips Terrence